so maxwell
yeah let's talk about elaine maxwell
last time we talked about elaine maxwell
uh
she had i think just been
arrested and we were kind of you were
kind of uh
telling your thoughts on what you think
was gonna happen to her a lot of what we
said
has unfolded when maxwell got arrested
the more conspiratorial
were saying that the fix was already in
you know she would get a pass somehow
and she would be let off so to not name
all of these people her co-conspirators
royalty people at the head of business
etc but we've seen in the courts
month after month motion after motion
go against her she offered a
multi-million dollar bail bond package
and the judge shut that down
she revealed that she she's married and
i think it was 25 million and
the prosecutor said you know she's got
multiple
citizenship france israel
the uk and
that money you know if she's facing a
life sentence
she could just easily walk away from it
we don't know how deep her pockets are
but we believe the money that she said
her husband was putting up
was her money in the beginning so
you know it's probably chunk change to
her uh with her assets she's got around
the world
then we saw as well as the
denial of the bail bond which has been
going back and forth
we saw the authorities putting
increased pressure on prince andrew to
cooperate in this
and he's still reneging
and towards the end of the year we saw
two other huge
players one in the epstein case one in a
case of his own
i'm talking about jean lupernel jean-luc
burnell got arrested in france
epstein boasted he had slept with over a
thousand
girls from jean-luc burnell's pipeline
from europe to america
including 12 year old triplets
and he was laughing at what good oral
sex they had given him
on his birthday as this present from
jean-luc brunel
so i've been doing a series of
interviews with a guy called fred on my
channel
he's out of france he might be a good
one for you to get on
who's an absolute expert in jean-luc
burnell so
he's at the forefront of this group of
activists in france
who are exposing this bastard
virginia has said that at the orgy on
the island
in which prince andrew was participating
this is virginia's words
in which maxwell was participating and
epstein
that they were joking that these girls
that john luke brunell had sent over
were the easiest ones they couldn't even
speak any english
and they were from these poor families
in eastern europe jean-luc burnell was
running a modeling agency
and you know they tell these girls we're
going to launch a career
come with us and next thing they're
getting sex trafficked
so the french authorities as well are
leaning on prince andrew to give
information
now is prince andrew you know and these
other big names
the slave maxwell's got up her the car
that maxwell's got up her sleeve
even if she does
it would be in the interest of national
security to prevent the information
forever coming out we're talking about
bill clinton
prince andrew multi-billionaires
leon black it's come out since our last
interview
gave epstein 150 million so epstein
when he died his net worth is around
half a billion
leon black who manages one of the
biggest funds in the world
gave epstein 150 million
a lot of that money must have gone to
the sex trafficking so you know
directly his money was going into the
sex trafficking of these kids
but nothing's been done to him so there
are these huge
names that seem to be untouchable
so the trial
is scheduled for this summer
and what maxwell has been doing is going
to court every month
and trying to increase her plea
bargaining power
because right before the trial
each side then we'll try and get
together
and based on the plea bargaining power
of the defendant
a deal will be agreed to avoid trial
i think that is the most likely outcome
it might not necessarily happen right
before this summer trial date because
that summer's trial date is like a
musical chair
they could push that back three months
six months they can keep going with that
but at some point i believe that maxwell
will have to take a plea bargain so
what does that mean she has to take a
plea bargain let's say she'd won all of
these motions
and she had a really strong plea
bargaining power just before
the trial they might offer her like five
to ten
so she gets up in front of the judge
shows remorse
and she's got all these mitigating
circumstances
the judge has had a nice breakfast that
day he's not you know he's in a good
mood
the judge might sentence her to the
lower end of that range
so if she's got five to ten judge might
give her six years
if she's going to court every month and
all the motions are going against her
and more witnesses are found and more
charges
are added to the indictment she is
losing her plea bargaining power
so by the time it gets to trial they may
say
look the positioning right now the best
we could do
is offer you 15 to 20.
now she's going to say right 15 to 20 if
i get 15
it's the feds i serve 85 at that time
you know
the best years of my life are over so
i'm gonna roll the dice and take it to
trial
and i'm gonna name these people but at
that point the intelligence agencies
would come in
and say look national security
you can't go there so these are the
forces
behind the scene at play
i've interviewed various people and they
believe that maxwell
is sat on the biggest
treasure trove of political capital
in the history of the world in terms of
who epstein filmed or recorded
having sex with these trafficked girls
so if you know if if she's got stuff on
the clintons
royal family members whatever it is
if she feels so trapped that she's going
to lose the rest of her life
she might want to activate that treasure
trove
and use that as some kind of
bargaining power but
biden has come in so we've seen the
changing
of the guard in the white house
biden and the clinton crime family are
like that
so we believe that
biden coming in will benefit maxwell
because that information will not be
allowed to come out
under a biden presidency with him at the
top of the fence
and again just like the title of part
one
there's always the possibility that
maxwell will get epsteined
what are they doing supposedly to
prevent that
she has a whole floor
of the jail to herself yep
she's not in a general population of
prisoners
she's asked to be moved to a general
population of prisoners so she can be
around people and have those
benefits but because of the nature of
her crimes
the inmate population is likely to at
the very least attack an extorter
or maybe even possibly kill her she's
being checked by guards
continuously she's saying that you know
they're waking her up when she's asleep
checking that she's still alive and the
place
is camera up like crazy just this week
her she started to fight back and her
lawyers filed something in the courts
and they're saying
that the only reason that she's been
arrested was because of the failings in
the epstein case because of his death
and that embarrassed the government so
to show that they're doing the job
they've gone after her
and she should have been arrested a long
time ago if they had a case against her
but i don't buy into that at all when
they arrest someone in a case of this
magnitude and complexity
the bureaucracy is very slow
but it keeps going and going and going
and going and they gather more and more
information
they get more informants they get more
conspirators on on the indictments and
that's how they build
these complex cases up i mean my case
was classified as complex case
over 100 people it took about um
i didn't do my plea back until the
beginning of the third year they were
still arresting people then
so these things can go on and on and on
but even though it is a very small
chance it will go to trial
i would love to see that if maxwell did
name some big names at trial
certain government agencies would then
have to take action upon those names
but it won't get there she will be
silenced either legally
or she will be epsteined
i